I thought I wanted to be a lawyer so I
declared international relations
thinking good pre-law thing and then
yeah you know I did all the Poli SCI and
econ and then in 90 the late 91 or even
early 92. I fell in love with the
internet
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
I'm with Kevin Tate from clearbit where
he helps clearbit to reach B2B companies
that are trying to better understand
their customers and optimize their
digital funnel he has over 20 years of
leadership experience in sales marketing
and product and deep expertise in
Enterprise SAS e-commerce digital
marketing social media and iot prior to
joining clearbet Kevin held executive
roles at SurveyMonkey chirpify and Shop
igniter
[Music]
I'm really excited to have you here all
the way from Portland right
that's right Portland Oregon where it's
now rainy and cold which is on brand for
us this time of year so we know what
we're getting into well we just had our
first rainy day in Tel Aviv so it's
saying the seasons are shifting uh today
your Chief marketing officer clear bit
but you've held a variety of really
incredible positions a favorite one for
me well two favorite ones for me first
the favorite one is that you are at
Stanford in 1991 during an international
relations which is probably like the
best thing to do there today maybe it's
engineering about IR is amazing there
and then obviously your role within
SurveyMonkey which is a company that
I've loved since I guess I don't know
like my middle school years so a lot of
the things for us to talk about today
you know marketing around summer rules
perspective from a marketing Revenue
perspective and and the way the data
plays into all of it and so let's see
what we can get in in 20 short minutes
and at least spark some curiosity but
Kevin why walk me through international
relations marketing sort of this connect
the dots for me
yeah those are some funny ones to
connect you know I thought I wanted to
be a lawyer so I declared international
relations thinking wow good pre-law
thing and then yeah you know I did all
the Poli SCI and econ and then in 90 the
late 91 or even early 92 I fell in love
with the internet and you know this was
right before web browsers were around it
was a lot of like oh gosh like gopher
and wace and FTP but there was there was
information out there that was trying to
get out in the sort of the
democratization of of of access to
information and I just I fell in love
with the technology and and what it
could mean for for society and for
business and so I ended up graduating
without with ir and you know focus on
econ but really spent my time you know
learning basic Unix programming and
getting into uh into the internet and so
uh when I had the chance to start
working on the web in early 96 6. I
jumped over there and so really the rest
of my career has been
largely internet software and services
how do you how do you put data to work
in particular to help companies grow and
help help markets improve I mean I think
that's so much the uh the promise of
data in its application is how do you
make things work better and create
better outcomes amazing so you've seen a
lot throughout your different marketing
roles and I'd love to hear your
perspective a little bit on how that's
been shifting over the last couple
decades and where are we at today in
terms of what marketing really is about
or if we're looking at the most
strategic way to think about marketing
from your perspective what what what
seismic shifts are we seeing here and
and what are we what do you expect for
the marketing world to take place
well there's a lot there uh about to
bust out the crystal ball I think you
know it's uh
it's fun I've worked I've worked a
little more in marketing than sales but
almost half and half in my career and I
think that um
you know it's an interesting perspective
because you end up working on both sides
of this go to market coin and um and
when I've when I've had both roles you
know it's me arguing with me over you
know what's a quality lead and what a
reasonable funnel metrics and what
should the goals be and so uh what it to
your question or on you know how do you
how do you think about that
strategically and how do you look at
marketing from that perspective what I
like to do is look at the role of
marketing
um not just as you know Legion or how do
I get people's attention and try to you
know Jam them through the funnel but
really marketing as Market development
which starts with what Market are we in
what Market do we want to be in and then
as we look to develop that market how do
we think about things that you know
today we talk about in terms of Ideal
customer profile how do we think about
segments and Beach heads how do we think
about the Strategic High Ground in those
markets and the cost of acquiring
customers isn't retaining and growing
customers in those markets all those
things fit together you know and you can
think of you know 10 different acronyms
that you put in those those different
buckets but if you look at it oh I like
to look at it through a lens of how am I
going to develop this Market over time
in a way that my company can create
value for that market and capture value
for that market and if I'm doing that
right right if the exchange is correct
there then I should be successful but
but but a lot of times these markets are
emerging and your company is emerging
and you don't know what's what's easy
versus what's hard you sometimes don't
know where the softer dirt is so a lot
of uh hypothesis forming and testing is
pretty key to to testing and tuning that
market development as you go along
well okay and so if we're looking at way
the way that that marketing is played
today and where it's calculating a
little bit a little bit now towards the
next few years if we're looking at
people that are that are thinking about
marketing landscape or to your marketers
or they're excited about the space and
the challenges that you just presented
how do you think people should
transition to think more strategically
to accompany to all the changes that you
just said
so I think part of it is is frankly the
goals you set and the uh the way you
frame the role of marketing and how it
should be measured uh in the
organization so to you know to pick
obvious ends of the spectrum if you say
hey I want to be measured on leads uh
and then I want to be measured on uh you
know how many people come to the website
then that's where you'll find your
marketing attention and budget
um and it goes right so all right
ultimately it's about the funnel
a step up from that is uh I want to be
measured on how much revenue we generate
right
um and now you're partnering with sales
or on Pipeline and opportunity creation
and ultimately closed One deals I think
that's a more strategic position and one
that you know gets you at a table that's
about Revenue not just funnel but even a
step further is uh the company's
strategic position in the market and if
you at least make sure that at least
some of the goals that you're setting
and you're talking to your e-staff about
or about your position and share and
development of those markets now you're
going to find that you're you're in a
much broader set of conversations right
that that's the stuff the board wants to
talk about right right that's the stuff
yep the c-suite wants to talk about so
summative is just sort of I don't know
setting your place at the table if you
will with what some of those goals are
um I do think to your question about you
know what does that mean today and how's
it changing
um we're obviously in pretty different
times than we were even six months ago
right and so a lot of the especially uh
B2B software companies are trying to
figure out
um of what was working then what's still
working now right really changed versus
what are we not sure if it's changed yet
or not and how do I think about my ideal
customers differently how do I think
about my buyers differently and that's a
pretty that's a pretty broad lens yeah
but to bring it back to those sets of
goals and and sort of how you set the
table
um I think a marketing team is going to
be a much better position to to work
with their executive team and to work
with their other go to market leaders to
navigate that if they build a landscape
for themselves that includes the
strategy the revenue and the funnel and
it's not just about hey the funnel's
broken How You Gonna fix it completely
because that's just that's a that's a
bit of a narrow View
I love that and I and I I love the it
didn't
the expansion from a strategic point of
view of Ohio you see marketing as a not
just a lead generation but how it how
the Strategic part of what it means to
affect markets to to funnel back
information to lead to revenue and to to
to create more much many more meaningful
interactions and decisions within the
company
let's talk about data you've spent so
much of your career dealing with with
data and obviously today with clear bit
and and a lot of the other experiences
that we mentioned reading out your bio
earlier to the audience let's talk a
little bit about the way that data is
being used today and from a marketing
perspective in your line of work
yeah sure so I can I can talk about it
from a clear bit perspective because we
certainly use data a lot and how we go
to market
um but then also that's what clearbit
does right so clearbit provides
companies with data about all the
companies in their Market
um and then helps them put that data to
work uh figuring out sort of who and how
and when to best engage their prospects
um and it won't surprise you to hear the
clear bit uses clear bit a lot and and
how do we go to market too
um so I think when you if you look at
the role of data and especially over the
last couple of years how it can be very
cost effectively applied and and I say
it that way because there there are
things that used to be possible but just
take a team of data scientists and data
warehouses and operational data stores
and all the things to try to get to some
of these answers and now it's uh they're
almost on temp I mean you you can get
these answers and put them to work but
the I would put them in the three
buckets I mentioned earlier
um who do you want to engage how are you
going to engage them in a way that's
relevant and then when like when do you
when do you spend the time and money
whether that's ad dollars or marketing
budget or sales Outreach effort when do
you spend it to companies and buyers who
are who are in Market who are showing
intent who are interested and that
triumvira sort of who how and when uh I
think is the recipe for a much more
effective go to market and data
underpins all of those
how how much of this is General versus
fine-tuned for different companies
approaches this broader question of
using data for go to market how how do
we tailor that to different Industries
different verticals different use cases
it's a really good question so I think
so some of it is general and then I
think the application of it gets very
specific so some of the general things
so I think
any any B2B company probably even b2c
but we mostly work B2B needs an ideal
customer profile you need a way of
describing for whom is my solution a
good fit and how do I recognize them and
that that recognizing Parts important
right because it might be based on how
many employees they have or what country
they're based in or what industry
segment they're in but it also might be
who do they use as their payments
processor or who do they have as their
CRM or their marketing automation system
or what combination of solutions are
they using that tell me I'm a good fit
to make that stack better so ICP can be
a lot more than just sort of a
demographic and firmographic information
but I think every company needs a
workable a useful ICP definition I think
they also need some workable view useful
view of buyer personas
and I say useful because I think um
there's there's a lot to be said about
so that the buyer Persona project that
takes you know six months and then gets
put on a shelf and maybe never used but
I I find the most useful piece is
being able to understand your key buyers
and their jobs to be done I I love the
jobs yeah and yeah it's amazing what are
they trying to do and how can you really
help them accomplish those jobs to be
done in a way that's that's valuable and
differentiated that's often really
really key to get right around that
product Market fit they gotta have an
ICP and you gotta have a view of your
buyers jobs to be done I think that's
General
what changes a lot by company and by
sector I think is how you put that and
the associated data to work in your go
to market and and maybe one of the most
um
important distinctions to make is what
is your go to market motion and uh
obviously that's a that's a spectrum but
to sort of turn up the contrast uh if
you are selling a you know six or seven
figure software product with expensive
Enterprise sales reps to Fortune 2000
companies then the way you use that data
to construct what's probably an account
based strategy and then tailor your
Outreach
Company by company even buyer by buyer
is going to be different than if you
take say a high volume or product-led
growth approach where you're trying to
start conversations with tens of
thousands of companies a quarter maybe
even a month and you're trying to figure
out how to sort of Shepherd them through
an education and buying process by the
hundreds or thousands your challenge is
much more like a sort of signal to noise
like how do I how do I read signals to
apply efforts as a portfolio to my
funnel versus how do I get this one
person to pay attention to me
um and so those are those are two go to
market motions both of which really
benefit from data applied to the ICP and
their buyer personas but the way you
apply it and the tactics that you employ
are going to be really different based
on those motions
I want to Circle back really quick to to
the idea of ICP the the ideal customer
profile for for non-marketers and over
the last few minutes can you give me a
bit of a better understanding as to well
what does this actually mean what goes
into this into the into this type of
persona and how do I somebody who's not
coming from the space but still I need
to be able to understand this and and
have coherent conversations about this
what what are what are really you know
over after 24 years in the industry yeah
what are your insights to to really
capturing this
I think I think ideal customer profile
or ICP is a is a powerful concept
because it acts as such a focusing lens
on on everything you do and to be clear
it doesn't have to be perfect and it
also changes but to give you an example
um uh if you if you're you know starting
a company or entering a new market you
know a common thing to do is say okay
what's my Tam what's my what's my total
addressable Market they're okay I want
every company from you know North
America and Europe and maybe other
places and I want to have this many
employees and you come up with this
massive massive number yes oh there's
you know 300 000 companies and this is
an eight billion dollar market and
that's helpful when you're trying to you
know show that there's enough
opportunity out there but it's not a
very useful lens through which to ask am
I talking to the right person am I
focused on the right type of company
with my valuable marketing dollars and
for that you need a definition that's
most at the opposite end of the spectrum
if you could talk to anyone in this you
know imaginary room of a hundred
companies who would you go talk to first
because you're most confident that what
you have to offer is something they're
going to value and be in a position to
buy
and then it and then through that lens
it's not these big General things it's
back to you know the things I mentioned
before like well maybe it really depends
what payment processor they're using or
maybe it really depends what size they
are
and what type of bookkeeping software
they're currently using and what
integration they have for sales for
right suddenly this mix of what stage
they're in uh what technologies they use
and how your solution fits tells you a
lot more about How likely they are to to
be your ideal customer and then there's
a lot of things in between but for our
for our uh clearbet go to market we use
our ICP definitions which includes
things like you know technology and size
and that goes we look at our whole
funnel through that so when we talk
about engaged companies or companies in
our funnel or New Opportunities it
always through this ICP lens and it
helps us know and understand
um the quality of our engagement not
just the quantity that's really really
cool over the last few minutes I would
always love doing is understanding why
do you do what you do why do you
obviously just having spent so much time
in the space you really do enjoy it and
you grow with it tell me a little bit
about what what's the satisfaction that
you get from your roles from the
journeys that you're on
yeah it you know I spent a lot of time
in
early and growth stage companies in
emerging markets and
um
you know it can be frustrating because
you're trying to figure so much out
right the Market's trying to figure out
exactly how technology and business are
fitting together in a new way the
companies are often trying to figure out
you know either how to initially go to
market or how to scale once they've got
product Market fit but I'll tell you
it's it's that figuring out part
that I really like yeah I really like
the the trying to solve that puzzle and
all the little mini puzzles along the
way right from Market entry strategy to
Public Market fit to scale to New Market
entry and it means you have to revisit a
lot of assumptions and and and re-figure
out things based on shifting Landscapes
like we have this year but uh for me
um that's what keeps it interesting and
and keeps it different and challenging
I love that Kevin I really want to thank
you for your time you know I love the
way that you're looking at at marketing
not just from your particular role in
the ways that you need to be serving and
um supporting the different
organizations that you're with but
you're really intentionally thinking
about the way that this industry is
Shifting and the role of the marketers
not just for lead generation but
focusing also on on revenue and strategy
for the company talking about the way
the data is played within organizations
and we got to chat a little bit about
the ideal customer profile and what goes
into that and not and and what really
was resonating throughout the whole show
is how how where how much respect
clearbit gives its own its own product
yeah its own its own
uh thinking process and which obviously
is a huge Testament to an amazing
company and so I really enjoyed this
conversation thank you very much for
being here best of luck with uh with
clearbit and everything else that you're
doing and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you sir thanks again for having me
thank you I appreciate it
[Music]